mind your decisions I'm fresh tell
Walker three runners XY and Z compete in
a 1000 meters race each runs with a
different uniform speed if X faces Y X
gives Y a start of 50 meters so they
complete the race at the same time if X
faces Z X gives Z a 69 meters start so
they complete the race at the same time
the question is if Y faces Z how much of
a start does y have to give Z so they
complete the race at the same time this
is adapted from India Civil Services
exam pause the video if you'd like to
give it a try and when you're ready keep
watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
now many people would think like this X
gives Y a start of 50 meters and X gives
Z a start of 69 meters so comparing y
and z we have a difference of 19 meters
this is close but not the correct answer
the reason is that Y is only running 950
meters we need the answer for 8,000
meter race so let's go through the
calculation we'll use the formula that
distance is equal to rate times time
which is often abbreviated d is equal to
RT now X is running 1,000 meters in the
same time that Y is running 950 meters
consequently we can set up the following
equations 1,000 is equal to X speed
multiplied by the time and 950 is equal
to Y speed multiplied by the same time
to complete the race we'll solve both of
these equations for T and since they're
both equal to the same T we'll set them
equal to each other
well then solve for y and get Y is equal
to 0.95 X we'll set that aside and we'll
do the same calculation for Z Z has to
run 931 meters now we could just go
ahead and say that Z is equal to 0.93 1x
but we'll go ahead and do this a slow
way we'll solve for T in each of these
equations we'll set them equal to each
other and then we'll solve for Z we get
c is equal to 0.93 1x we have two
equations and we'll divide the second
from the first the X terms cancel out
and then this fraction simplifies 3.9 8
it'll be convenient to write it as 98
over 100 which is equal to 980 over a
thousand well then exchange the 980 and
the Y to get Y over a thousand is equal
to Z over 980 this means Y runs 1,000
meters in the same time Z runs 980
meters 1000 minus 980 is equal to 20 and
thus we get the answer that Y has to
give a 20 meter start to z I think this
is a great problem because it has a
slightly counterintuitive answer
thanks for making mind your decisions
one of the best channels on YouTube as
always thanks for watching and thanks
for your support
[Music]